the problem is that the internet and the
internet conversation it just can't be
ignored i mean it is the sort of the
most vital um you know or it is it is
the vital locus for cultural
conversation today I mean you know Here
I am talking to you for you know big
thing calm um and the you know the 22 to
get out of the homogeneity to get out of
this kind of barrage of a sort of tiny
little disposable cultural bits that
sort of his our lot right now
essentially requires you stepping away
from this internet this internet sort of
scrum this internet the giant sort of
cocktail party that is the internet and
saying you know that doesn't matter um
but that's very very difficult to do
because you know the attention right now
is all coming from the internet um and I
don't think I don't think that it's you
know to me um I don't think it's wise or
I wouldn't advocate anybody just turning
off their computer and sank you know i'm
going to go completely Luddite and and
and head for the hills not only because
i think that that's a you know not
necessary but i also think that it's not
really desirable i don't i think that
that what's going on online is too vital
to completely turn it off to completely
say well this this you know doesn't
affect me and I'm not going to take part
in it but I do think that people need to
step back from it a little bit set aside
time in their life away from from the
internet away from the sort of
constantly always on way that people
tend to follow culture today that people
tend to consume culture today I think
people need to carve out spaces in their
lives for for contemplation and for
working on bigger projects that to me is
the solution and that I think is the
solution to what you're asking about to
which is um you know how do you
how do you sort of step back from the
homogeneity which of course is a
homogeneity that's born out of constant
novelty and I think that that you don't
want to step away from entirely but
neither but but neither can you allow
yourself to just stay completely
marinated in
well i think you know we are social
animals and um you know we you know part
of the part of the reason why we like
culture is precisely that we like to
talk to other people about it that we
like to be sharing something with other
people i mean you could say that culture
is the sort of social space between
people and that we would be a you know
not very effective humans at all if we
if we weren't um you know inherently
interested in the things that other
people are interested in um you know I
think that so yeah to me you know a lot
of this stuff about the herd mentality
and the bandwagon effect you know we a
lot of times code that as being you know
conformity and entirely negative and we
see it you know we think about the Nazis
or something but of course it's just the
basic stuff of what it means to be human
um and you know to me a lot of this kind
of internet culture what makes it so
fascinating is that the tools of the
internet allow us to see what other
people are seeing to track what other
people are viewing you know we have all
this data that allows us to see you know
what's what's popular and what isn't and
so we have all of these tools that let
us see it you know where the herd is
going and so it makes it that much
easier to follow me